and businesses across the valley have a
short amount of time
to make sure that all their employees
who are indoors and around people
wear these and there is some frustration
tonight but county leaders say
that this new mask requirement is
necessary
i'm a little disappointed that we're you
know we're going back to masks
for months employees at grouchy john's
coffee were given the choice to mask up
or not if they were vaccinated but
starting thursday that will no longer be
the case
a little disheartened that we've come
this far and it feels like we're taking
a little step back
i hope that the numbers would improve
enough that we could
keep moving forward clark county
commissioners voted unanimously tuesday
night to require
mass for employees when endorsed in
public spaces at their place of work
regardless of vaccination status the
decision a result of rising coveted
cases and stagnating vaccine rates in
southern nevada
public comment was heated we'd want to
see each other's faces
your political theater must stop leave
it up to us to decide our health
commissioners realize any mass
requirement is not ideal
we don't want to do this but if things
don't get better they're worried about
our medical capacity and the possibility
of conventions
canceling trips to vegas but the risk we
run is that we aren't going to be able
to have access to hospital care
and or we are not going to have an
economy that thrives and neither of
which are acceptable
employees at this summerlin restaurant
never stopped wearing masks and managers
agree with the county's decision
actually 70 percent of all of our
employees got vaccinated
but we still mandated that they wear
masks things are going to be status quo
for us here businesses trying to look on
the bright side
i'm glad that we don't have to you know
argue this point with our customers yet
i hope it doesn't get that far
again the new mask requirement goes into
effect tomorrow night at midnight
and will continue through august 17th
when the county
will revisit the issue now county
leaders also decided tonight that
larger venues and major companies such
as the casinos here on this strip
have to submit a covid mitigation plan
and they're also asking businesses to
put up new signage such as this right
here
asking everyone recommending that they
wear their masks again according to that
recommendation
from the southern nevada health district
last week reporting live in las vegas
tonight orca mana 8 news now